Успішний контрнаступ ЗСУ на Харківщині з новою силою розпалив у Німеччині дискусію щодо поставок зброї Україні.
Безпрецедентно стрімкий і масивний наступ з часів Другої світової війни, визнають більшість міжнародних експертів та західних лідерів,
став можливий передусім завдяки озброєнню, яке поставив Україні Захід.
Таким чином аргумент багатьох противників поставок озброєнь, зокрема, у Європі про те,
що більше зброї для України лише затягує кровопролитну війну РФ, втратив сенс.
Натомість на тлі досягнутих успіхів, впевнена голова комітету Бундестагу з питань оборони Марі-Аґнес Штрак-Ціммерманн,
конче необхідно продовжити поставки.
Українці неймовірно борються.
Але зрештою цю війну можна перемогти лише, якщо буде достатньо зброї, аби захищатися.
І через 200 днів після нападу РФ на Україну потрібно сказати, що росіяни вже програли цю війну.
Усе виявилося не так, як собі уявляла Росія. Але було б фатальною помилкою нині вважати,
що Україна іде в цей наступ і війна закінчується. Насправді це означає відвоювання регіонів, які за міжнародним правом належать Україні.
І нам потрібно зважати, щоб люди тепер не сказали: та й досить, все не так вже й страшно.
Важливо говорити про це. І важливо, щоб Німеччина і надалі виконувала свої зобов'язання підтримувати Україну і постачати зброю.
Представниця Вільної демократичної партії Німеччини, як і більшість її однопартійців, наполягає на необхідності якомога швидше
підтримати контрнаступ українців поставками важкого озброєння, зокрема БМП Marder та танків Leopard 2.
Саме такої допомоги очікують від Берліна і в Києві.
Не буду приховувати, що основна тема наших переговорів сьогодні - це збільшення та пришвидшення постачань озброєнь для України.
Цієї осені розраховуємо отримати першу надсучасну німецьку систему протиповітряної оборони IRIS.
Я також не міг не згадати останню ініціативу, так званий "План Леопард", яка з'явилася в німецькому просторі.
І наголосив дійсно на важливості постачання з Німеччини танків цього типу. Ми не бачимо жодних перешкод для цього.
Минулого тижня німецькі ЗМІ повідомляли, що Київ запросив у Берліна 100 танків Leopard 2 та запчастини для них.
Утім, на відміну від IRIS-T, необхідні Україні танки у самій Німеччині вже стали таким собі "яблуком розбрату".
Так, представниця соціал-демократів та міністерка оборони Німеччини Крістіна Ламбрехт
услід за канцлером Олафом Шольцом днями відхилила прохання України про постачання бойових танків.
Головний аргумент обох представників СДПН - Німеччина надаватиме підтримку Україні лише разом із союзниками.
Крім того, політикиня пояснює відмову нестачею необхідної військової техніки у самого Бундесверу.
Мовляв, через тривале недофінансування армії ФРН на папері все виглядає краще, ніж на ділі.
А Бундесверу ще необхідно виконувати вимоги НАТО, підсилюючи східний фланг Альянсу в Литві.
Щоправда, генсек НАТО Єнс Столтенберг не так давно підкреслив, що підтримка України наразі важливіша,
ніж наповнення збройних складів країн НАТО згідно уставу.
З цим погоджується і голова партії Зелених, яка теж входить у склад правлячої коаліції ФРН.
В інтерв'ю німецькому мовнику ARD Омід Нуріпур закликав допомогти Україні відвоювати якомога більше своєї території до настання зими.
Питання, чи не послабить таким чином Бундесвер свою оборонну спроможність, на мій погляд, навряд чи постає.
Бо питання в тім, що захищає Україна.
А якщо Україна захищає нас, а про це усі ми говоримо вже багато місяців, тоді це інвестиція у нашу ж безпеку.
Щодо "Мардерів", то ми знаємо, що на складах виробників вони є.
Ми знаємо, що танки є на складах Бундесверу, тож відповідно треба зараз якнайшвидше зустрітися
й поговорити з країнами-партнерами про те, як якомога швидше допомогти Україні. Це вимога часу.
І, якщо бути чесним, через два місяці може бути запізно, адже тоді для відвоювання територій не буде таких можливостей, як нині.
Оглядачі вважають, що дискусія щодо поставок Україні танків надалі лише посилюватиметься.
Думаю, німецька правляча коаліційна партія СДПН, а також Олаф Шольц опиняться під наростаючим тиском
з боку Вільної демократичної партії та Зелених у питанні відправлення танків "Леопард-2" та інших важких озброєнь,
постачати які Україні Шольц досі не наважувався.
Зрештою, схильний вважати експерт, це може призвести до того, що в майбутньому українська армія
зможе розраховувати на важкі озброєння з Європи.
Про готовність відправити в Україну 16 відремонтованих старих БМП Marder із запасів Бундесверу,
щойно буде дозвіл уряду ФРН, 13 вересня повідомив і зброєбудівний концерн Rheinmetall.
Ще 14 БМП вже в роботі.
Тим часом очільник українського МЗС Дмитро Кулеба на свїй сторінці у Twitter вже відверто заявляє:
Та чи переконає такий випад головного українського дипломата німецького канцлера?